are you one of these who only chooses to
wear a seat belt when you're driving
fast on the freeway like if you're going
below 30 m hour no that's not fast
enough I don't need it excuse me you
know Usain Bolt the world record holder
in the 100 meter dash do you know what
his top speed is about 25 miles an hour
here's what you do go up to him and say
I'm going to put a brick wall at the end
of your 100 meters don't slow down just
keep running face first and tell me what
happens he'll look at you like what do
you
idiot what okay that's exactly what'll
happen to you if you're in a car not
wearing a seat Bel going 25 mil hour and
the car goes head first into a brick
wall you keep going the car stops but
you don't you keep going and your face
breaks the
windshield that's why there is no speed
where it isn't safe to wear a seat belt